sorry
welcome again the first item on the
agenda for the audit and risk committee
today is on the open Set current heaps
part is the health and safety report
Nikki do you want to speak to this
no we're not yes we are
um not in general it's pretty
self-explanatory I think it's just a
matter of taking baby steps all the way
forward as we've been going so each
little project that we are continuing to
put on our list of things to move
through it's just a continual iteration
of The Next Step The Next Step but I'm
happy to take any questions anybody has
in regards to how we're tracking Along
on that health and safety area
does anyone have Michael Mr chair
several years ago we had a look at the
asbestos situation with all the
buildings in the council and so it's
good to see that we're getting awareness
but has there been any progress or
what's the plans
on managing the asbestosis risk
through the chair
um there are no plans that I know of but
it is on my radar and I am aware that
we're supposed to have things in place
for it but we don't at the moment but it
is on my radar
the three water staff also have it on
their radar when they're doing their job
starts so they have
um particular breathing gear or they
identify it beforehand when they're
dealing with it in the pipes or whatever
so it's part of our new regime is to
complete the job start so should it be
there at one time the plan would be made
to deal with it at that specific point
in time so just keeping it on the radar
really
is there any other questions
on the health and safety report
thank you Mr chair
um
just to Unity if
are there any um defibrillators between
here and at the library
yeah through the chair um there is one
that lives at the library we have looked
into getting a second one that would
stay in this building there's actually a
massive shortage on these and they're
really hard to get at the moment I think
something to have covered still hanging
around
and so as soon as they are available we
will get one but currently they are only
supplying them to the ambulance or
understandable thank you for that yeah
because I guess the library will be open
as
that Council isn't so it's probably
important for that I bet we had some
inside information with Matt and
macarook who's been very busy at St
John's trying to find us one so so we're
on it
are there any other questions
uh through cheer thanks
um
are there any confined spaces training
for your staff and what they're using
and do you have any designated rescue
processes that you have to adhere to if
you have a staff member in trouble
uh yeah we definitely do lots of
confined space training air three Waters
guys always get put through that
and we keep it refreshed as well in
terms of rescue plans that's a question
that I can ask three Waters and get back
to you I don't know myself off the top
of my head but I'm sure they do
um just to follow up to that a
designated rescue plan should be part of
the confined space and it would probably
be just nice to show on you last year
how many people have actually gone
through your confined spaces training in
the future thank you yep no
question
the given the excellent report that the
Auckland city council was subjected to
given their failings over the Auckland
flooding as anybody in the council sort
of scheduled to read that and think
about how it might impact Encore if the
same sort of thing was to happen
it's something that we're going through
as part of EMS so part of that committee
but Jason might be able to speak on it
more
was he describing them like sorry
yeah you're just through that you just
couldn't re uh I guess confirming uh Mia
Bell's comments there and uh a lot of
those sort of learnings from I guess the
Auckland uh
the Auckland experience for lack of a
bit of term
um uh part of proposed training sessions
for staff
um to occur over the coming months so
there's a National Training
um I think for later in the year and
there's also a local training uh
opportunity for EMS staff in uh next
month I think it is so there'll be
certainly some stuff from there but
again one of the advantages that
Southland has over Auckland is the
collaborative group through Emergency
Management Southland and the direct
connection between the group controller
and the mirrors and so that was
something that was certainly a
identified issue out of the uh the
Auckland
um Auckland flooding
not to sound like a crack record
um
going back to the flooding I studied the
Gisborne and Napier flooding quite well
and looked at the records and I saw
there's a severe lack of warning given
to the residents and low-lying areas and
we've been talking to environment
Southland for the last three years I
think I've mentioned that we need a
warning system on the waikika river in
waikika Valley and that has not been
implemented as of today
and um
we need that because we need early
warning for escort we got caught badly
in the last flood and came over there
was no sandbagging done at the Rubbish
Tip
and that should be something that we
should be set up
but there's no action by es so I think
we need to put a bit more pressure on it
just for out of the safety point of view
so councilor Reed yeah thank you Mr
chair completely agree John
um we know ourselves that in the 2020
flooding it was the council staff that
stepped up and took over and did a
magnificent job of warning the residents
seeing all sorts of things that they
should never have been put in that
position to do so you would expect some
really decent action from ES
foreign
possibly one advantage we've got here
over up north we've had a few floods
over the years
I came to Gore in 1979 and we had a
couple of floods in the early 80s the
paper mill so we're reasonably
experienced in dealing with them
the other Advantage is you've got more
competent people
but I didn't say that
mayor B and Bell
I'm just gonna
talk about the complete opposite and
fire just notice that the fire drill on
the 10th Factor was delayed do we have
an update on when that may be occurring
yes so the facilities manager has said
that we're good to go
that just not to do it when we have
people in the building
there's a key that they're expecting
that it will the fire curtain will go up
and go down that's what he's been told
will happen if it doesn't go comes down
we can't get it up there's an extra in
an override mechanism
so we can practice that so we've got a
date for next
we didn't stay yeah next Wednesday we
will be doing that and we'll do that
while the library for the first one
while there's not actually people in the
library so we'll get it done first off
and then we can practice getting the
fire curtain up and down when there's
not people on there
councilor Stringer I just on that
um can you please notify the fire
service will make sure whoever's
performing fire test notifies us because
we have had call outs to places that are
running a standard test and we don't
actually get that over the pager thank
you
we always inform the fire service yeah
I've got to keep pushing this button is
there any further questions or comment
on Nikki and Report
if not could I have a mover that the
report be received pounce the guard on
favor please say aye
aye against carried
I didn't bring to keep that on
policy
prioritization for review now this is a
report
done by Morgan Edwards welcome Morgan
uh through the chair thank you it's my
pleasure to present this report on the
policy prioritization for the audit and
risk committee the content of the report
is relatively straightforward
um
it deals to the policies which contained
under the risk audit and risk category
in the policy register
equates to eight such policies all of
which have been prioritized as you would
have noted when you hopefully read the
report section one deals to a pre-size
of these policies going through relative
um
or individual aspects of those policies
I should note at the outset or close
enough to the outset that this is a
prioritization document rather than a
full-on
policy analysis however having said that
I would imagine that barring
um
comments made through or made by
relevant managers or people in the know
of such policies that um
there may not be much in the way of
revision uh done to these policies but
nonetheless uh the section after focuses
on uh what a w policy prioritization
Matrix
It aims to provide
a or an impartial analysis uh or
prioritization of the policies it's
based on the principles of Health
funding methodologies which of course
are very values based but they have to
limit
the scope of some of those values
[Music]
um
with all the different
aspects of the prioritization Matrix
that go through
uh various schools given and the cherry
on top of the cake in this instance the
ordering of the policies on page seven
gives a full uh review and full score
um for the policies to review and of
course they ordered as such
um with those being on the highest or of
the highest priority are at the top and
those which are deemed relatively low uh
priority uh at the bottom
and that is
[Music]
um
that is the report
I'm in now at your disposal for
questions
thank you Morgan
do we have any questions from Morgan
possibly more comments and questions
because this report is really about
determining the work program for the
next 12 months on policies and so if you
skip to the end and you look at the
answer it's hard to fault the answer
uh but I have a couple of comments one
is
if we haven't reviewed a policy
it seems to jump to the top of the list
and so that's the principle that the
Matrix delivers doesn't a lot of the
other things seem to be a lot more
subjective and it really comes down to
have we reviewed it or have we not
reviewed it and if we haven't we it
jumps to the top of the list and I
wonder whether there's Merit and looking
at how frequently the possible policy
applies
and so therefore how important or how
significant it is to the day-to-day
operations as to whether it's priority
but that's it's sort of a comment not a
thing but you can comment afterwards and
the other one is I look forward to the
review of the investment policy
because
I'm not sure that I agree with the
comments and hear about
government bonds
and I would argue that uh
to say a lack of
there needs to be more discussion on
what is the true risk of a Government
Bond and why you would own one because
the reason you own one is because of
liquidity and marketability it's not for
any other reason and therefore the issue
with the UK Pension funds last year had
nothing to do with interest rate Rises
and therefore the Fallen value of the
bonds you can actually trace it back to
20 years ago when the accounting
standards
effectively forced most Pension funds to
go 100 bonds and that was always a
terrible decision and so it was that
decision not the actual
policy stuff but I look forward to the
review on that one
through the chair or thank you for your
comments uh on the first comment I
absolutely agree with you uh bearing in
mind that this is the this is the first
iteration of the policy prioritization
Matrix it will be polished and gleaned
and cleaned in future for future use by
myself and other staff members of the
council for other prioritization
um
means uh on the second comment uh I we
could have some very interesting
discussions on that but for the purposes
of the committee we'll uh we'll leave
that for now
um but yes hopefully things of that
nature will be uh within the document
more uh in deep than what this are but
the the
reason for
um inclusion isn't to to get Eventing
off on some intellectual Odyssey
um
uh rather it's to demonstrate or at
least look more in depth
um at the specific stipulations of that
policy
um that of course being a useful or the
so the example of government bonds is a
useful example useful tool through which
we can analyze the operations of that
policy a little bit more
um Fitness
thank you once again
two other comments Mr chair one is it
would be good to have a comment or a
column that actually identified if
there'd been a legislative change that
impacts on the policy
and another column that identified with
a management had identified any issues
in applying the policy because if they
had then that should
Advance the review
through the chair yes I do I do agree
um that would
make things a little bit easier and to
literally or for tractability of going
through and seeing what legislatively or
the legislative context was of the
legislative context had changed in the
intervening period so yes I agree with
that too thank you
are there any other comments or
questions from committee members
give me a bell uh more just a bit of a
comment into build on uh what Michael
said as well
um just looking at the sense of
expenditure policy um just because I
looked over it because it was one of the
ones that got accepted uh prior to the
election
um I recognized in that going back
through it
um that it referred to the old
guidelines rather than the guidelines
that the the auditor has provided
um so I I don't know whether that
changes your weighting scale at all but
I just noted that so some seem to while
they have been refreshed may still be
subject to review I think I agree with
your ranking there overall it's not the
highest priority but also the other
points I wanted to make was around
um since what it has asked us to look at
that policy and update it whether that
changes the ranking as well it may not I
just thought I'd mention that the other
point I wanted to make and comes back to
the report that we discussed earlier uh
is a round of where to do this
recommendation just making a slight
change to the recommendation that these
dates are added to the policy so we know
when they will be up for review
um that hopefully helps out Lorne a
little bit I'm taking the boxes
foreign
I would say on the sensitive
expenditures policy and without that
increases whether it should be reviewed
or not I think I'm very serves it's
towards the bottom it is at the bottom
um given the frequency of committee
meetings it may
not behoove us to move it up
um and to keep it where it is
um it also gives us time to take into
consideration in the other movements
that are or any other changes to
self-offered by or an extrapolated by
the office of the order of the general
and other best practices
um
uh it may come up so I would my thoughts
are just at the moment to keep them in
to keep it and where it is now
um
yeah I think we've got no other comments
to to make regarding another comments
thank you
through you Mr chair the um just to
elaborate on the auditor's comments the
auditor's comments related to the year
into the 30th of June 2022 and at that
point at 30th of June 2022 the sense of
expenditure policy hadn't been reviewed
it was reviewed in the subsequent period
between the 30th of June and the report
being
um released and we when we provided
management comments back to them last
year we said it had subsequently been
reviewed so it was it was reviewed the
oag's guidelines were used and provided
to elector members at the time and there
was I remember some quite robust
discussions and they were comfortable
with where they with where they landed
so
um yes it's one of those policies that
we do like to review on a regular basis
um so you know annually to biannually
the members can choose what they what
what review cycle they want when we come
Bruno comes up for review so
through through the chair there
um in regard to the discussion we've
just had
mythology methodology that we have there
uh we have five areas that we work in
obviously based on health funding which
is obviously
um interesting in itself but
um looking at that if we
how do we add enough the solicitor
general or whoever audit's going to
decide to
Bend these where do we include them in
those um five points for your
prioritization
so obviously these are open to a bit of
movement are they
'll be open for movement and as we add
in for more policies that get added this
is like we said this is an initial cut
and you know we're happy to be having to
be challenged on the rankings at any
time this is you know what we put in
front of you
um so yeah we the officer of the
audition General adds more what they
want to see from us as a regular program
a regular review program and it's
unfortunately policies are one of those
things drops to the bottom of everyone's
list when they get busy but it's no
excuse and we um and again that's why
we've recognized and got the fixed term
resourcing initially and can put it to
elected members as part of the annual
plan to look at bringing their member on
permanently getting policy analyzed
permanently to show how we are taking it
seriously we do take a responsibility
seriously in this area and we know it's
an area for improvement we like to
improve
and well yeah our general manager just
made the comment that the policies may
be reviewed annually or by annually I
think she might have meant by innerly
okay
um Bell sorry just to be really fine um
would we be able to get that policy
changed then if you did use the current
guidelines it just refers to the the
older guidelines and the current ones I
think it's only like one or two words
that need to be changed but if that's
what was used set
I'm fine it's a very slight tweak it's
just that's where my confusion came from
so
um if elected members are happy for
their policy to be amended for that
small change then we can we can make
that change
is there any further discussion on the
policy prioritization and review or do
we want to change any of the
recommendation that the E and the
they're all going I'm happy to move the
recommendation Mr chair and I'm also
happy to add in that we change those two
words in the sensitive expenditure
policy
okay well similarly we recommend to
cancel that that gets changed
secondary for that
sorry could I just add to that as well
just the comment made earlier around the
adding these dates to the policies just
at the bottom so yeah but um yeah that's
in my recommendation in my emotions
happy to second that
so any further discussion all those in
favor say aye
against
Kerry
can I just ask to see procedural
question you've just passed a motion
that something be recommended to full
Council
and I'm just wondering the step it goes
through because my understanding is
before it can be recommended to full
Council the minutes need to be approved
and there's nothing in this Gene door in
the previous agenda where there are
minutes so what's the step that it goes
through for that to be approved as true
and correct before it goes to full
Council
excuse me
too adoption sorry
okay my point is though that it's the
committee that must approve the minutes
as true and accurate before they go to
council surely
it doesn't not with the Committees okay
the council just goes straight to
council the council accepts them as true
and complete and accept and adopts or
ratifies the recommendations that are
put forward
welcome miles
can you hear us
it's looking a bit
walls
we have a technical glitch
so
can you hear a smile
thank you
thank you all right
well welcome miles do you want to take
us through your report please
let's have what's happening now please I
think is that what yeah
uh
Signature Bank in the U.S as well
well they moved into big one which was
ub's Swiss bank and uh
pretty sweet site and they they had to
be bailed out by their tribe or the
other Swiss paid UBS it was sort of like
a false narrow tree because
um
Swiss count from the Swiss different
thing
for the secrets for special day if they
actually uh
but this is actually with with inflation
and with um
with anything we've just had
as
[Music]
severely critical energy problems as
well I don't really need
Ed and some have been
what technology
disability in oppositions that
previously very so it's the latest one
that happened in New Zealand so if
interest rates in the states of life
the quick story on it as a result yeah
the inflation story and it was very
danger prices
um
in New Zealand we we haven't uh
support of all the important bits of
economic data recently were being
the inflation rate
and then to
um
so yeah and 7.2 for the year so it
increased by 6.7 of the year they've
been expecting soon so it was a lot more
than expect one of the main reasons for
it was a form of Transport classes
now that's an important one because
things for the receiver called the New
Zealand's one of the last quarters to
get its GDP number out that one of the
last countries to get a GDP number out
and uh
if if it seemed the portrait came out at
the end of March will give the match
called at the end of June if
we are
a chief medical definition or a season
we've already finished that quarter
ironically
assume that is if we are
um
The Reserve Act and probably the other
names of the important one was The
Reserve Bank in the for monetary policy
review not a monetary policy statement
but a monetary policy review they
points now they had previously been
expected but because of the managing
crisis
uh that the mini big crisis a lot of
badly participants I think about 64
spent 50 chance of
like 52 chance that it will only be a 25
Reserve people resolutely
April monetary assigned the speaker and
monetary policy statement so
recession
engineer or stations right
the monetary policy review there was no
hence that they would slow the base
they wouldn't get their
phone now
would
uh sort of traffic on their own dealers
to control the Flash and they have
firmware for legal inflation is the
number
of Henry the New Zealand that's the one
that needs to be afforded with the The
Unwanted that
um I suppose you have shortened cheated
consequences as recession and so we get
excited they were right ahead and down
conversation
inside
is the reason why uh
we are still probably a bit of an
outline Central basis that you know
that are not secreted in this country
that's in the face of the time he's got
the markets and the resumes are still
now predicting one one more line
events
at four point two five four point number
six
interest rate team forward and they had
fallen quite sharply we've still got
what we call an inverted yield curve
where
short-term rates to higher the marketing
rates that's quite unusual
it is a previous year there's Apprentice
It's a recession last year in 2009
0 obviously we had
again so
actually there's the iron even put out
which countries
obsession
probably more
romantic for the completed life of his
expectations
um so that's the economic background uh
is a really like it wasn't too quick or
too cumberleaded are there any questions
on that one
sorry just on the hike there
um with that one more hike what's that
it intended to be what's the prediction
on that
thank you
uh the Christians on the economic
Outlook
counselor guide on
just noticed and deposit rates have
started to drop and whereas real
interest rates haven't
um there is sort of it will be a must be
some sort of changeover soon or with the
cash rate going higher it will push
those short-term costs higher but
deposit rates are seem to be going down
any other questions from all
it just has any comment from people
Michael for example on Swap rates
against fixed bonds coming further out
which would be the better option
yeah nine out of ten years you would
always go for a fixed rate bond over a
swap but there's sort of you know in 10
of the cases the market just becomes
silly and underpriced certain things and
now as possibly
okay the the other comment I'd make
about interest rates
as the short-term interest rates are
governed by
what the Central Bank wants to do to
manage inflation
and the long-term interest rates are
driven by what the market how successful
the market believes the central bank
will be
and so with interest rates at the
five-year Mark lower than the one year
mark and the three months Mark it's just
simply saying that the market believes
that the central bank will drive
inflation down because the central bank
is saying we're going to keep going
until we have driven inflation down so
it's sort of one is all about the market
and the other is about what the Central
Bank wants to do
but it's on it's unusual times at
present
so
is there any other questions for miles
any other comments
well
how are we performing compared to other
councils on our average interest rate
cost
and
we've just been here today
Council from another advisor and it cost
to bonuses 5.8 per se
so it's unusual but most
amazing in the middle sort of in the
middle half I would say that
the cost of the average cost of plans
would be around about four point miles
at 4.2 I thought about 4.5
a little bit
um
that we didn't people that they would go
up this quickly but interestingly uh
there was a
presentation
their their plumbers I'm their
economists and their first comment was
wrong wrong wrong wrong wrong
and it's amazing
as far as
saying
it's been the unexpected and antenna
consequence of the typing I'll be easing
outside the amount of tree Young
there's no flavor
I thought simply it's thought about
pouring a lot of money into the system
it would write the economy around so
simple
um
thank you that's the
is there any other questions or comments
okay I suspect the reason why our cost
of funds has gone up relative to other
councils is because we've borrowed more
relative to other councils and if you've
borrowed over the last 12 months so that
over the last 12 months we've borrowed 8
million and went back for another 3
million which is quite material in the
context of the debt that we've got and
so therefore that explains why ours has
gone up but it's yeah but I'd still say
it's competitive and when you look at
the the OCR
at five and a quarter our cost of funds
is less than the OCR so that's the
ultimate test
so
um
your cost the increasing your cost
advances
but interestingly on the
uh on the report the interest rate
rejection
if you if you see that it's on well it's
our slide uh five on it
risk management
if you've got that the interest rate
projection chart on the bottom left
the Blue Line the one in the middle is
your projected cost of funds so you can
see it goes up a little bit it does
decline
is the domestic
so I think you're pretty close to the
peak in what you're interested on
because I'm the only way to beverage
interest rate and
and for
um and if you didn't have time
almost indicated that it will then you
could be borrowing at lower rate so that
it should decline in your custom funds
will be more pronounced
I'd say what this grant does so that we
have a quick strategies in the future
that takes the markets particular track
of the 90-day rate
anything I'll say in America
is that um
it's
only going to happen in reality an
interest rate exactly the projected to
today our business report was written
and I can probably say it was a high
degree of student there would be
anything I can say is that they might
end
within the exit for anything else it's
the best prediction that there is and
it's the market s on any one person's
production it's not it's an Hull
okay is there any other questions or
comments for miles
thank you miles could we have someone
moved that the report be accepted John
Garland seconded Paul mcfail
all those in favor say aye
I against carried
we now move on to three Waters did that
thank you miles
but we now move to three Waters debt
settlement update lornay
thank you Mr Chia and through you Mr
chair this is up don't forget
her no I'm meeting with the national
transition unit went on the 29th of
March
um I have provided with a lot of other
information in the background that's
just for for information purposes you
can see some of the volume of what we've
been getting this on a small portion of
the tsunami of information that we
receive from the interview on a regular
basis but for the council our
negotiations went quite well we had
quite robust discussions with the
representatives from the NTU and we have
managed to
um from and have talked to other
councils
um or equivalents at other councils at
the Forum last week the Strategic
Finance Forum not many of them had
thought to try and
a portion of Porsche our part of
corporate debt so we have a part of
corporate debt there three Waters was
going to be contributing towards we were
taking rates that would contribute
towards you know things like um
I guess software packages uh the
buildings and things like that that you
know as a collective everyone was
contributing towards all the activities
centers we're contributing towards we've
managed to secure a million dollars
worth of that debt to be paid out by the
NTU as part of our debt settlement
you know the key thing for us going
forward is that balance when it does
come to settle
um
the the formula for which they work on
is f and net debt which is a debt mine
air through water State minus at the
three Waters reserves is less than 20
million then we'll get paid out up front
and we can settle the debt if it's more
than 20 million then they are proposing
it back to back and they'll only settle
as our current debt matures and up to a
five-year period
the ideally for us would be 20 million
we understand there may be some
ability or some scope to look at those
councils who made for between 20 and 25
million and and settle those as well but
we'll see we'll see how that pans out as
we know that's an ever-changing
landscape
um you know from from the time we had
this meeting here the the landscape has
changed the data settlement has changed
and now they're looking at pushing it
out to um first anywhere between
first of July 2025 to first of July 2026
depending on where you are and where
your entity your new entity um ends up
so they're talking about new entities
coming on Med here not just at a
year-end or a year beginning mid-year so
some entities will come on part way
through a year which will make things
very complex going forward but for this
for this report date settlement we're in
a good position
um and net and net debt at the end of
2022 was 14.33 Waters plus the million
Corp which is 15.3 at least 3.3 in
reserves so effectively our net data at
that point was 12 million what they do
going forward is take the movements from
a Financial Funding impact statements
and their movements in debt and reserves
from now going forward and that'll be
taken into the equation from there but
that's their starting point is a net
debt of 12.3 at 30th of June 2022.
John Council got on will that didn't be
now that we've got because we've had a
few bills since and um Auntie is placing
about 47 yeah
three years chair I haven't haven't got
the exact numbers in front of me but
three Waters debt currently makes up
about 40 of our overall debt
um 40 to 42 of our overall debt
um we're pushing that as part of our
year-end our year-end work papers and
annual report program
so I'll be able to give you an answer
into the into the new year
anyone else got questions
about
thank you Mr chair I don't know if this
is the right Forum so just stop me if
you don't want to answer here but
um just with the the pushing out of
dates um not to get too political but
does that put us in a worse off position
holding on to that debt for another year
or two or is it something that we had
planned to to have anyway in the in the
past
um
just just know that we're not getting
rid of it as 2024
um through you Mr chair there is some
modeling work we're going to be doing
um going forward we want to get the
annual plan out of the way and we
um we'll be modeling what that actually
looks like and what it means for the
council the council did make some
strategic decisions based on
three Waters transferring on the first
of July 2024 we'll need to revisit those
and the long-term plan will be part of
part of that process we revisit that so
as part of the long-term plan we will
look through the scenarios we have a
we're working with a new model that will
allow us to
um stop three Waters part way through
the ltp cycle so with rewards without
three Waters and do some different
scenarios on this we'll be able to
provide better information for elected
members going forward as part of that
ltp discussion
two questions firstly is there anything
that we can do to ensure that we're one
July 25 not one July 26 so we're because
as I see the longer it goes the more
likely we are to be above 20 mil and the
second question is if three Waters gets
pulled because of change in government
or whatever do we get paid some
compensation for the cost to the Council
of assessing this
um through us this year there's been no
talk of compensation if it gets pulled I
mean that will be up to the
um if it is the new government that
comes in and makes that decision then
that would be up to them to come up with
a plan we could place pressure on them
as far as the decision for the first of
July it would depend on the other
councils within a entity so at the
moment with the new 10 entities that's
effectively otago South and in the
techware design agreement from all those
councils to go ahead at that date so
there's a bit of discussion to happen I
guess regionally at that and we are we
are well connected regionally
um air Jim general manager of critical
services and regular meetings with um as
part of the heads of of the regions so
they meet on a regular basis and Jason
might like to provide some comment on
that
through the chair I think that the
biggest problem that we've seen since
the announcement of the changes is
um
the greater I guess uncertainty for
everyone so at the moment
the feedback coming through from the NTU
um
is around is basically I will we will
tell you more once we know more um and
so
um that's the level of certainty that we
currently have um and that makes it um a
pretty big challenge for us and I guess
there is however to answer
um Michael's comments around
um trying to go early I think this is
certainly a desire from the chief
Executives of the otago South and region
to get
um that transition over the line as soon
as practicable and questions have
already been asked about how we can move
towards the front of that queue if
there's an opportunity to do so so that
will continue to gather more momentum I
think over the coming sort of weeks and
months
foreign
happening at a at a governance level is
uh there's definitely an appetite there
to to go early
um and the minister has indicated that
he won't end the interview have both
indicated that they won't stand
um in an entity's way if they do decide
to go early
um it's just that conversation along
with that modeling of what does going
really look like what are the benefits
versus costs um there's also the
conversation around because now we've
been split from Canterbury and West
Coast
um whether there's a there's an appetite
there to to rejoin or not
um so that's all stuff that has to be
work worked out everything's pretty up
in the air as is but Jason I'm all now
alluded to
just Michael's question on the 20
million wasn't answered
do we um well we definitely being a
later date we'll definitely shoot over
20 million
through the chair that will depend on
the long-term plan discussions and what
projects that the link to members
approve going forward and the facing of
those so again that's going to be a
pretty a pretty interesting discussion
for long-term plan
um and as as Jason's alluded to you know
we're still very uncertain about when
everything's moving so it makes it very
very hard to plan to model
um and try and predict what's happening
we the the other things that we need to
be as a council need to be aware of and
we'll consider as part of this is the
the debt ceiling and with three Waters
coming out and the revenue coming out
that drops our debt ceiling limit and so
we've got to do all the work around that
as well to see what to see what impact
that has but also has an impact on our
rates and how we set our rates and with
that big portion of targeted rate comes
out that pushes us over our uagc's and
general rates so again this is why it's
a really interesting time to be in local
government really interesting time to be
doing the revenue and financing policy
and starting that discussion I believe
next week as part of the revenue and
financing policy review so those are all
important decisions that we're going to
have to make we did indicate to the NTU
Representatives that we will be that we
will find it a challenge with three
Waters coming out with around air rates
in the uagc so
um we will you know we will work there
that they're aware of of the challenges
for smaller councils in their in that
space
are there any other comments or
questions
if not would someone move that the
report could be received
Michael seconded by councilor Reed
now for discussion all those and favor
please say aye
all right against the merchant is
carried
right
we now move to the last item on the
agenda which is the risk analysis
assessment report
so
general manager of community and
lifestyle Services I'd like to speak to
the report thank you chair um through
you
um
the development for this report came as
a result of various strings and strands
of
feedback and conversations that came
across my desk
primarily from Individual elected
members
um but also from
other community Representatives
nationally regionally and locally so
what was identified was the
the possible need to bring this in front
of the audit and risk committee because
as you are aptly named I mean it's
around risk
and
as of sitting near the in the start of
the front page of the report it's to
look at this particular situation
through a risk management perspective or
from a risk management approach
um and uh and it I think it's probably
important that we reiterate that it's a
journey that will be on and as far as
looking at that from a risk risk
perspective and through a risk
management lens
I'll take the report obviously take the
report as read but do
I suppose want to
focus a bit of a conversation
around
the risk liens that we are talking about
the situation through
um and and I think also it's important
and I think I've noted it again in that
cover page of the report
it's an opportunity for us or for you as
the audit risk committee to call on the
expertise and experience of Michael as
an independent member to also provide
um that overview and um and and that
Independence related to the topic in
conversation of risk and risk analysis
and risk risk management
so I think the situation as as is in
front of you is reasonably well
understood hopefully
um
and uh at the top of the um at the top
of the table
um talks about that situation being from
various aspects around relationship
breakdowns around public confidence
around trust issues around privacy
breaches around leaking of confidential
information and subsequent to writing of
this report it's also been highlighted
to us from from media
feedback that that it's maybe not just
leaking of confidential information but
they've been a source of confidential
information if you were to listen to the
podcast from Tim Brown from Radio New
Zealand the other day at one minute 51
seconds he talked specifically about
differentiating between leaking and a
source so so those are the um that's the
lens from a risk perspective
that is put in front of you
um and then obviously as a result you as
a council have already or that Council
sorry not this committee but the council
has already
requested an independent review
um into rebuilding their trust and and
those opportunities related to that from
a governance perspective be be
undertaken
but I do want to highlight a suppose
we'll reiterate
um
that the risk or the description of the
risks have are in no particular order
so they're not prioritized as being most
the most significant or whatever that
that's not something a mere officer like
myself would want to get involved with
uh in terms of identifying on your
behalf what might be identified as the
the most significant or the highest
priority risk because I think what what
we've been able to do through this
process is identify that the likelihood
of occurrence and all of them is high
and the likelihood of significance and
all of them is high and that's obviously
the test with respect to risk risk
management
um and and then looking at mitigation of
risk one other thing that I will
highlight is uh it's been it's been
raised with me prior to the meeting that
um I didn't we didn't talk about
um
external intervention and the risk of
external intervention and I purposefully
didn't include it as a risk because it
actually may be a means of mitigation or
some of these risks that might come
through
so it's a it's a fine line when walking
that balancing rope of what is a risk
versus what is a mitigation for a risk
and so again I think it's an opportunity
for you as uh as the audit risk
committee to um to discuss that
um happy to take any questions with
respect to
the the the the columns in relation to
the risk description in terms of
likelihood and consequence and how they
have been assessed and in terms of the
just general comments related to each of
those risk descriptions and you'll
notice in the final two columns around
around risk mitigation approach and
action by of lift that really for the
political conversation to be had I'm not
wanting to meddle them that
um but but take on board your discussion
and conversation with respect to that
because this as I said before is
something that I think will as a journey
and it's something I think through the
recommendations you'll see is something
that this committee needs to be over for
the next period of time and obviously
also be feeding some recommendations
back through to council I'll leave it at
that Mr chair and like I say happy to
answer any questions but
hopefully utilizing the opportunity for
this committee to actually enter into
discussion to provide the feedback and
input that we require going forward as
well
thank you
come on Michael
I think it's a it's a good discussion
starter and we could all individually
debate some of the rankings and I don't
think that's so important
when I look at it I think we need to
separate out the current situation
because as a committee I think all we
need to gain Comfort is that there is a
process being put in place to address
the issues of the current situation and
as long as that process is in place and
as a as a committee I'm not sure that we
have any other role and therefore in
part I'm more interested in
what we do from a risk point of view
to mitigate these sorts of things
happening again
and the consequences to the council if
they if they happen
and
perhaps the most serious one is the
breach of confidentiality
now because everybody is human we can't
prevent somebody choosing to breach
confidentiality
but that's quite serious because it has
implications in terms of the council
relies on trust in the community and the
council relies on democracy and we need
to make sure that we value democracy and
we honor the voice of the people but
if the council has a leak or the council
or or somewhere in the council has a
leak then people will be hesitant to
talk to council representatives and that
will make it very hard for the council
to operate going forward so to me
we need to be thinking about what do we
have to do to
train people and remind people about
confidentiality about privacy to train
people
and remind people about behavioral
values
that
the public would expect of of the
council in terms of management and
counselors those are sort of the
where this issue comes to me I think
from a risk management point of view
that we've got to be forward-looking
not trying to relitigate on this
committee what is being addressed
elsewhere
and
at the end of the day risk is all about
unknowns if we knew what was going to
happen most of the risks would disappear
and so we've got to sort of Look Over
the Horizon at what are the unknowns and
perhaps
with the benefit of hindsight
we hadn't thought through the issues if
there was going to be a uh
what happens if there's a complete
change in Council
that's not something that we had
discussed at this committee which is
probably something that we need to
because we should value democracy and
the people's will is to change then we
have to work out what we do so yeah
that's a ramble
but I'm more concerned about what we're
going to do to remind everybody about
the importance of confidentiality and
remind everybody about
behaviors and remind everybody about the
Privacy Act and the importance of
privacy
thank you Michael I couldn't couldn't
agree more I believe that the Privacy
our confidentiality breach is the thing
that keeps me thinking about things at
night how did that happen because the
person who has done it has not just made
a comment because of podcasts and things
they have let the whole lot go we all
can be guilty of suddenly thinking oh
sure as that was in committee and I know
I almost did something the other day and
then thought hell I can't say this
question I said that word
that was a committee meeting so
immediately an in committee discussion
so we can all get caught on an
individual comment but this breach we've
had at present is
a deliberate full leak if you like so
thanks for coming now
and I also want to make a comment or
sorry counselor Reed no thank you Mr
Chief
um excuse me I guess Michael in the
answer to what you're just put to us as
the um we will be undergoing further
training very shortly
um so that's a move in the right
direction and I guess one of my other
worries for us as a council apart from
the confidentiality breach which affects
us all particularly in the community
because we have a very divided community
at the moment and it's not something
that anybody
um likes having to deal with but it's
actually the effect that it has on staff
and do we have flight risks and staff as
well because of pressure and also staff
recruitment going forward I think we'll
get you know it's always a struggle for
a small Council who can't meet the
market financially and
um we try and offer them all sorts of
things but hello we're obviously a
council with problems so who wants to
come and work here so I think we need to
look at that
valve
when I first read the report
I thought well we've got the review
going on is there a lot we can do so
thank you Michael for the added context
in terms of looking at it more generally
and and moving forward
there's probably
um half a dozen different things that
could populate every one of those cells
and I doubt that it's particularly
productive use about time and and the
committee meeting to
um
go go through an exercise and look at it
and I I would think that in two months
time we probably are in a position to
actually fill in a number of those cells
with the training and other things that
we've got going on
um so what I'm wondering is whether
you want to set up a small working party
tasked with reporting back to Linux two
monthly meeting
um is is a means of giving some
direction and
um
yeah just a thought
what do other counselors think about
that
councilman Richard mcfowl
he's just treated the chair I actually
um I agree with what uh Michael said
about look in the rivers and may have
been retrospective okay we've got a
process that is in play
um when we think about the fact that
we're actually uh
putting this back towards the full
Council there's only three councilors
around here
so you've actually got eight of the
council sitting in this um in this
committee so I think that probably
um forming a smaller committee we've
we've probably got enough in play at
present
to try and realistically move us forward
maybe put this we have a table we have
it monitored it is there it's a document
and process that
from the risk point of view we
definitely have to recognize and
acknowledge there's a number of matters
in there that are beyond the scope of
the actual counselor situation which
involves obviously staff and
reputational Council and employment and
that sort of thing
so why
feeling would be to place us to the side
have it recognized militant processes
there but move forward with what
we already have in play uh
I don't think there's anything else that
possibly I could add to that
the other comment I meant to make is
well it's a council decision because
it's in the public Arena I would
actually front foot it
and put in place a pro hack excuse me
proactive communication program to
actually
put information out into the public
so there was no nobody can accuse the
Council of hiding Secrets or cover-ups
or anything like that I think that
that's probably something else that
would be beneficial to you one rebuild
the trust of the public so that actually
people do want to come and work here
because I suspect the gore District
Council and the local government sector
in general is going to be quite an
exciting place to work from a career
point of view for the next decade
Council Australia
it's through to cheer um
I'm guessing the manager of community
Lifestyles would have some solutions
some there from mind as well and
probably might like to be in the
subcommittee
she was she I think it's a process as
has been pointed out both
specific to a situation but they're more
General as Michael has alluded to that
yeah I think we would it would be a
great opportunity for governance and
management to to get in together and and
actually uh co-design and and develop
the approach going forward I think it's
a real up and then that's a that through
action is a real good example to show
both internally our staff but also
externally our community how we're
working working collectively and
together through these approaches to
create the solutions so
are there any other
comments Council Council mcfarl Richard
mcfail
it's uh just through the chair to the uh
the general manager there
um
when do you think like in regard to
where we are we should be putting this
process in play or do we put it in play
today
because we've still got a lot of other
information that needs to be dealt with
and
also processed or
um
other matters that probably have to pass
through
Council Council
discussion and possibly debate
um prior to putting this
situation or process or document into
play
I'm just looking for you know what your
gut feeling is
see through three years here it's a
really good question and it's actually a
difficult one to answer in the sense
that we have to I think and Michael
summed it up very well at the start
there is there is an actual situation
that we or you as the council are
dealing with that we're going to let and
you've started that process off so I
think we've got a
allow that process to continue
and you've you've already committed as
uh the governance arm of the
organization to a number of
for that particular situation for a
number of
um initiatives which will assist in
mitigating risk
so so you already have an extraordinary
council meeting tomorrow that you're
dealing with you have
um already committed to a number of
training opportunities
um
related to that particular issue but
which will flow over councilor mcphail
So Into The General
the general
um
issues that Michael has raised and I
think from looking at the general issues
that Michael has raised I'm comfortable
to make hay slow in in that particular
area because the flow over or the ripple
effect of some of the work that you'll
be doing as a result of the situation
that you're in and and the review that
is going to take place as part of that
as well
will assist in dealing with some of
these General matters
and and so it's not so so they won't be
or they will be offered it will be able
to operate it concurrently
um so hopefully that that's
provided some direction around that the
other thing I would say
um is that
there will be some areas of risk or some
of these areas of risk that are
identified here that will have a
slightly more management Focus than a
governance Focus
um and and and vice versa so it's not
always just a you know going back to
council stringersport it's not just a 50
50 split of of equal role in
responsibility and I I think the
opportunity does exist as per what are
the recommendations there that we just
bring this back up you know because this
committee meets bi-monthly so that this
is something that becomes a recurring or
a recurrent report back on this risk
mitigation or risk analysis and
assessment lens that we're that we're
looking at it through
so Council mcfail I think
it's it's we've got a couple of things
running parallel some I think some will
run faster than the other but the other
will catch up eventually
councilor Paul mcfowl
been sitting here the whole time so I
thought I'd better say something thank
you general manager for the report I
think that's the effect that we're
actually going over this report and
discussing it shows the public that
we're actually we're concerned I think
what Michael said about notifying the
public and letting them know what's
going on in a more broader area a right
way is essential as well and there's so
many pieces in here we look at
um that that are absolutely relevant and
I just thank you for bringing that to
their attention thank you very much
thank you chair
um I totally agree with Michael I think
there's a real opportunity
um potentially with the endorsement of
Sonia of maybe doing a bit of a press
release around actually what trainings
we're going through
um whether that might be a good idea
because I think we've got three if I
believe so it might it should be good to
signify to our community what we are
doing and what we're being trained on I
think it's it's a good value for our
community I just want to touch on a
couple of the points that Michael made
one being around the lake
um
I know we're getting training is there
anything further we can be doing to help
mitigate that I'm I'm not entirely sure
it's just just putting it out there to
the floor
um and my second thing was
um around the the risk that bronman Reed
um sorry counselor Reed signified around
staff do we have the same issue with
elected members
um I see there's a by-election do we
have a risk around potentially not
actually having someone who wants to
fill that slot because I know that you
know with the media attention that we've
got I don't see a whole lot of people
signing up for the job
um just as once again putting that that
risk lens on things but um first the
mitigating licks up
councilor Stringer uh Justin response to
that some of us have already taken a
conscious step of not bringing our cell
phones or any outside digital media into
meetings in there as well so there's one
more process we're doing
oh
mcfail
it um really uh obviously we're heading
towards the recommendation there and
obviously what we've discussed I think
with the basis of what the general
manager said I'd be happy to um
to
put forward emotion that the reports
received I don't think there needs to be
any alteration there the only thing is
that we need to make sure that the three
members who are not here are aware that
this um obviously we've discussed it
here as soon as possible so whether they
haven't checked it I know it's on the on
the Hub but uh where we're going to do
that and I don't think there's any other
guidelines or any other
um
reference matter that we need to include
there and I think it would be a good
document as a source document to refer
back to that runs parallel with what
we're doing and what we're heading
forward on
just really and it could be a living
document the fact that other matters
that come up the council as a whole
could add
um
matters as they come forward so I'm I
support the recommendation
but yes thanks Mr chairman oh yeah sorry
I wasn't a second I just wonder based on
your points Richard around the three
members that aren't here whether it's
actually something that should be coming
to full Council same same report same
basis but to Full Count so it might work
in well because you've got to buy buy
monthly report on the relationship side
of things as well so it might be worth
bundling it up into a whole item but
does that make more sense than excluding
those three councilors
foreign
I would be happy to um to I think we'd
still
we still keep the intermediary report
separate to the risk report but I would
be more than happy to furnish a report
to the full Council after the each of
the audit and risk committee meetings
it's not any extra work really and it's
just a matter of getting it into another
Forum which also gets the community eyes
over it from a different lens as well
which I think is important because you
know as it's been pointed out this is as
much for the community
a reassurance to the community as it is
to to all of us internally and
externally so I I appreciate that and it
would be happy to follow that up so just
the clarifications of were you meaning a
report to audit and risk and then a
report to full Council or just skipping
out ordered and rescue together and
going straight to full Council I would
still encourage you to bring this to the
audit and risk committee I mean it is an
audit and risk committee and you have an
independent member who provides another
set of eyes and some experience and
expertise that I think we can all
benefit from
think of that clarification have been a
second
okay Council counselor Val
I'm still wondering who's going to fill
in the blanks and these selves we seem
to be going around and a little bit of a
circle and I think it requires both
governance and staff input so you Mr
vagina
oh sorry let's try and assist councilor
Havel with an answer
um
and I think we need a formal resolution
but what I'd suggest is that if you're
comfortable I take the responsibility on
to pull or to to start to populate this
and
um and then
send it out for any feedback input
involvement and just manage it through a
simple
administrative task like that rather
than trying to create another series of
meetings and bureaucracies that if we
can get away with we don't need and and
I'd be happy to
volunteer to coordinate that and pull
that together but asking for your input
to then start to like you say populate
that for the next audit and risk
committee and then the following council
meeting Etc if that's if that's the wish
of the committee
councilor reval I'm comfortable with him
we have a mover and a secondary is there
any more discussion or
just adding to some of that report and
some of the risks we probably need to
look at too like the one thing going
right back to the starters having a
pretty much of a hang up on the vote for
22 minutes like that that transition
period of a month like
do we have any sort of plans in place
for if that ever happens again or
looking down the track
oh can I just
something was discussed that that we
possibly should have done in hindsight
was the three members who weren't
challenged would form a committee at the
uh to transition if that happened again
I think we'd learned enough from the
exercise that when we come to this next
if the remembers not challenge they
become part of the team and that and I
see the
Rex is nodding so I think we could
that's how we would handle it and next
time around
so we went left
yeah just further to that I think
Michael's pointed around the risk of a
complete Council change of valid I mean
we had a complete change of the
community board this year we might not
get unchallenged people and you know a
fit in a
theoretical World
um is there then a discussion towards
the end of our Collective term um to put
some steps in place maybe six months out
from the election of of how a transition
unit would would work
okay is there any other discussion or so
I'll put the motion all those in favor
please say all right all right against
carried